what if red skull joins Ayesha and the
sovereign that we saw in guardians to
galaxy vol 2 and he joins team Adam
warlock it's like a buddy cop show now
but it's red skull and Loki it's
revealed that that NSA connection that
gave John Walker u.s. agent the shield V
it was Red Skull the whole time this is
rogue theory once again from just the
void that we all are stuck in this is a
show where we put some wild theories
from our well-read skulls about the red
skull
guys I'm Philip Alena and joining me
here digitally as Holograms of course
I'm Erik Bosse hello I'm a well-read red
skull well wishing you some redness in
those cheeks so that there's still blood
flowing through your out your veins you
know what Eric's been working on in
isolation
it's like tongue twisters and my best
Thomas dish we also know what's in that
cup he's drinking he never has he keeps
not having anything in that cup and I
don't know why people are distracted you
have the driest tongue you need to wet
that pity cat hate speaking of all you
cool cats and kittens we also have
Austrian preserves producer Zac hey I'm
the colonel matthean of new rock stars
I just want to say I'm happy to sub in
for Tommy Bechtold this week he's off
talking to all the world leaders to make
sure we get this taken care of so that
the Buffalo Bills season is not delayed
so let's build nations this is wrong
you're proud he doesn't know what else
is going on or why it's going sued and
marina masters how are you holding up
I'm good yep I'm inside
I see now I'm not buying it I have a
feeling what we'd spend our breaks doing
is nerdy stuff like just watching the
entire MCU we're in the middle of doing
our infinity saga rewatch right so we're
still early on if you want to join us
but as we're going into it we're looking
into these lingering questions about the
MCU all these interesting characters
that are established in the background I
mean will they come back will we see
them again and the one that is obviously
maybe that one of the biggest lingering
questions in entirety of the MCU is Red
Skull now this guy was the villain all
the way back in Captain America the
First Avenger which is Eric's favorite
movie because it features his heroes
Nazis are your big Armand had yeah
yo Zola for life or likes property of
Zola or your crotch so you showed up
again an infinity war an end game and
then he lost his job just like everyone
else so we all want to know what is he
up to now this guy needs a job guys
pitch me on how Red Skull is going to
return to the MCU okay I got a theory
red skull was on Vermeer he was the
stone keeper for the soul stone and
there was an alternate version of the
Vermeer sequence from end game that was
released on Disney Plus with Clint and
Natasha and in that deleted sequence
Thanos is forces arrive to basically get
to the soul stone first in that moment
it's hilarious Red Skull just goes peace
he like disappears and apparently he has
teleportation powers which he did not
have
without the power of the space stone
beforehand but clearly this guy went
somewhere and you can argue whether or
not that deleted scenes Canon or not but
that guy went somewhere so you have to
ask where in the cosmos have we seen the
MCU where his values and his philosophy
would be most appreciated well red skull
is like a crazy extreme eugenics
obsessed geneticist he's like basically
the pure blood wizard who believes that
every everybody should bow down to like
the superior blood and race that sounds
a lot like the sovereign in the Enclave
so the people who created Adam warlock
there are people who look down on mixed
race and people who they believe are
cross breeds and they believe in like
perfecting one's DNA to create the super
superior being so you can imagine what
if red skull joins Aisha and the
sovereign that we saw in guardians to
galaxy vol 2 and he joins team Adam
warlock which is basically space Jesus
his game is perfect and we're gonna see
him in guardians of the galaxy vol 3 as
like the weird caretaker to Adam warlock
who just kind of worships basically a
more refined version of what red skull
was going for in the first Captain
America movie so so we're gonna combine
forces they're bred skull and Adam
warlock I really like the coloring of
that image by the way because red and
yellow are the most contrasting colors
like the McDonald's logo yeah McDonald's
I wish Erik I feel like I need a scene
from this where I very clearly hear a
Red Skull impression give you a scene
from this movie okay so imagine a
intergalactic courtroom scene Living
Tribunal is a judge overseen all this in
the debate is kind of like the Scopes
Monkey Trial right
it's about evolution it's about
evolution in genetics in the MCU after
Thanos who was an eternal with a deviant
gene wreaked so much havoc the whole
universe is turned again
people who are not genetically perfect
derivations of like the Celestials right
so on one side you have like the
guardians of the galaxy who are arguing
like hey it doesn't matter where you
came from or what's in your DNA we're
all kind of like you know crossbred
freaks and that's okay whereas on the
other side Chris Pratt impression yeah
other side you have Red Skull who is
arguing another crossbred freak like the
mad Titan Thanos who believes that the
only way is population control that
blood that is allowed
nothing hard that thinks shriveling Erik
you obviously I mean you earned a Rogi
for that do what did it become on you're
a free frigate spinner I got a big time
it's gotta keep spinning to hold its
value better be a perpetual spinner but
you can place it on any anywhere anybody
like and then confused and then I just
want to point out that I I really like
this this idea of Brett's call coming
back I think it's weird if he's able to
just leave for me her whenever he wants
cuz then he's not really being tortured
but I still like it
but also I'm still just giving the first
ones for your theory the second one is
for your impression that I'm giving you
the second rogue he became red eye drops
by the way black and red he held it up
to the red skull colors just saying
they're also not see colors which is
dark ball they're also the new rock star
colors Eric you picked those clothes you
made me I wanted the United Colors of
Benetton two directors to look good all
right who's next
have an idea so I'm gonna get out of
here guys I'm gonna lead with my red
skull impression oh I love it it's not
gonna be a scratchy but so I rewatched
captain market last night and at the end
you know they're having that big battle
and you know everybody remembers this
but he goes I have seen the future and
so on no flags
or maybe he says flags please
so no fakes oh and he also this is a
totally different scene but you know he
also says victory with the W's in the
vide yes Eric wass yeah yeah Eric was I
took him so seriously and he's so
threatening except for the one time in
the movie he says quick tree but so he a
wittle baby ooh you want what do we now
that he's out of a job
right he's pooping around Vermeer he
can't not in my pitch he can't just like
teleport off because he couldn't tell
her it off to begin with it was a
tesseract that took him there so he's
pooping around he's stuck and at the end
of endgame Loki actually has the
tesseract right he stole it so the first
place that Loki is gonna go is if Gamora
was able to able to figure out that a
soul stone is on Boromir then I think
Loki is gonna be able to figure that out
too so he pops to warm air to go get the
soul stone and Red Skull is like hey
like before you leave before you bounce
like let me pitch you like my mission is
basically the same as yours
his is Loki's is like universal
domination they both want all the stones
they're both on a mission to find all
the stones but Red Skull is like okay
cool like I'm on the same page as you
let me take over Earth like let me do
your bidding like I'm I'm gonna be like
a lap dog but like what's like a side
dish like a vassal yeah
like yeah or aside this reign over this
domain or exactly like like he's willing
to let Loki be the ultimate ruler but he
still has like beef over what happened
so he wants to be in control of earth so
he hitches a ride with Loki and and the
way that he comes back into the MCU is
through the Loki series so we find Red
Skull as we're going into maybe the
first or second episode and and they
hope they Cooper on the universe
together and they become buddies
murderous little tykes whittled I don't
like seeking out whipped wheat so I like
this I feel like you got to pitch me on
a twist because these are two bad guys
teaming up with each other but yeah I
mean they are and this is like I mean
the Loki series is like okay Loki is he
good is he bad right
so 2012 Loki is still bad but there is a
still there is still a future right
where eleven years later whatever where
he's kind of riding the line between
like is he good is he bad so this Loki
series the twist is like Red Skull is
there to be to sit on his shoulder and
be his bad like angel like he's pulling
Ares devil he's pulling him toward the
dark side and the whole series is like
will we watch Loki stay bad and become
bad or will we watch him slowly over the
course of like a couple of seasons
basically is he gonna be a pull what's
the guys in Breaking Bad Walter why is
he gonna break that is he gonna be a
Walter White or is he gonna be Jesse who
starts out bad and basically becomes a
good character yeah exactly
so that is is interesting because 2012
Loki alternate 2012 Loki does not have
goodnesses necessarily have the same
journey that our Loki has so he has to
have a whole different reason for why he
might turn into a good guy eventually
it's a different timeline but the
potential of each person I believe is
the same like no matter what timeline it
in your in the reality could be
different but deep down every person has
the same potential within them so
could end up good just for totally
different reasons like you said but he
also could just stay a murderous little
think about some of that was beautiful
right you're gonna get a rogue II the
rogue ease that be on my side they
become nice pretty decorative stones oh
oh okay
marina that pile is one row game you
tried to make it too easy on yourself a
whole pile and you better keep it if you
lose any of those stones that's a
fraction of a rogue utilization alright
well you can look around while we move
on to Zacks theory okay so here's what I
think and and and just to be clear the
the Russo brothers did say after endgame
that now that um you know Clint got the
soul stone that Red Skull is like
released of his duties to guard it right
so he's a free agent he can do whatever
he wants but he's still alive and some
kind of weird floaty way right so here's
what I'm thinking the two things are the
one main thing we still know about Red
Skull right it's he's got to be pissed
off at Captain America right that's the
guy that he was fighting that he wanted
to be partners with kind of cuz he was
like hey were these two super soldier
DUP guys like we should be running
things not these puny humans whatever
but Steve Rogers was too good to do so
Reds go got zapped into space but he
still has a beef with Captain America
but of course Captain America in this
timeline is now an old dude and the Red
Skull doesn't want to go beat up some
old dude right like I've tried it it's
fun
but it's a fleeting fun yeah you had
that's why you had to leave Florida I
mean technically everybody you fight in
Florida is an old dude but so learn
alligator so he still wants revenge on
Captain America but not the physical
person Steve Rogers the more the idea of
Captain America so flash forward to the
Falcon and Winter Soldier series okay we
know this character u.s. agent is gonna
be involved we've seen riah Wyatt
Russell
we playing ham we saw that in the
Superbowl ad spot he's kind of he's got
the shield right he's got kind of the
cap esque outfit
seems like he's playing the captain role
and and let's say that like after the
events of end game even though cap gave
the shield to Falcon right Sam that the
government was like actually this
belongs to us we have a trademark on the
Captain America name so we'll be taking
this shield circle are right this is
ours and they give it maybe maybe
through the the guise of like there's
this senator in charge of the security
committee or whatever or a top NSA guy
and he hands it over to why at Russell
who you know does the does the pep
rallies and it's kind of the face of for
the government of the kind of Captain
America program but quickly he's a
stooge he turns bad he does some bad
stuff he gets some terrible press if
he's like you know carrying out weird
assassinations for the government all
kinds of terrible stuff boom it's
revealed that that NSA connection that
gave John Walker u.s. agent the shield
be it was Red Skull the whole time the
whole time the whole time because we
know right in the comics it wasn't as
emphasized that in his movie appearances
but red skull's a master of disguise
right and so he was he was the whole
time he had a weird plastic face on as
as some senator or a deputy of the
interior or whatever right nobody
noticed that the dude is that way ya
know because he does he have a wife and
kids yeah oh yeah he committed you
really committed to the role yeah a
little-little red skull baby red skull
the dog so this is all like his plan to
discredit the Captain America brand more
so than the person he wants to like wipe
it off the face of the earth and have
only bad associations with it how cool
would this be for the Falcon a Winter
Soldier Disney Plus Series if in this
series we got Baron Zemo Bucky and
Red Skull the villains from all three
Captain America movies in the same
series that's like even though we won't
have Captain America probably very much
himself like there's there's some nice
continuty there yeah Zak I'm giving you
a Rogi for the first reveal tomorrow my
god it's so valuable on your side then
I'm giving you so that the reveal ye
roasted people anytime you feel off a
face and there's another I like how
people would think like oh it's gonna be
a mass it's gonna have another play and
it just is dread viscera like underneath
I'm giving you a second Rogge for that
connection of all three of the
[Laughter]
possessions
they're made of the books behind it they
used to be more and then I was gonna
give you a third one because I really
liked this idea of all three of the
bones I was gonna double reward it and
then you pronounce continuity
continuously you lost it right there so
do I get it now usually when you ask
that I feel like I have to I have to
give you one you just have something you
want to show off I know cuz that would
also take you to three no sorry
Eric you've taken enough from Zach I
just want some of this toilet paper I'm
willing to I can spare roll brother
just roll it all right let's see him
back in the tweet light sweet simple red
skull's racist
so he's cancelling what so he doesn't
come back
oh he comes back what is these cancel
just just to get canceled yeah it's rare
you know that's his ruling okay we won't
say it sweet rules me a tweet bad boys
three more like a buddy cop
Cirie's Loki and Red Skull pooping
around the universe as best friends and
then it's a picture of both of them with
their friends up and then a the
merriam-webster account replies to you
and asked for definition I'm poking
around since in Houston so many times on
a mission to collect all the Infinity
stones that's exactly what pooping her
house it's like you know when you're
pooping around you know on a mission to
collect infinity
Thanos just pooping around Thor was
poking around from place to place put
things in your basket the things in your
basket are Infinity stones and your
basket is a gauntlet but this specific
definition in Zack you take in honor of
Tommy back to Falcon in Winter Soldier
never dough
what's behind that face it's red skull
hashtag Tommy best on hash tag builds
mafia just you're the only person that
looked up to Tommy back top he's like
Daddy which makes you my granddaddy
oh well stay away from me because I'm in
a risk category all right and you have a
perkele you tend to fight yeah
all right guys before we move on to our
next theory that I'm actually really
excited to get into which we got to give
a huge thanks to our sponsor for giving
us a huge thing to be hugely happy about
I'm talking about your wieners you two
ladies we're talking blue - say it with
me now you got to chew the blue to spit
the game you guys want to be confident
in the bedroom am i right yes
for once in my life but current events
have made me real soft and sad normally
current events right now you need some
help from modern medicine who are the
real heroes we've established this but
you don't want to get Viagra or Cialis
those are expensive and those are brand
names and you don't need those also
they're harder to get but you know
what's not what's great at getting new
harder
blue 2 it's cheaper and it's made in the
USA you don't have to spend time waiting
at your doctor's office or at the
pharmacy again though I keep saying it's
nothing to be ashamed of go to your
pharmacist scream at them I need help
with this quick she's in the car you
they can actually do a just like this
we're gonna do a live one here they can
do an online consultation so Eric go
ahead and show us what you deal with
okay just blur this great no sure sure
so if you look like a spinner digit
spinner guy but you can't catch it stick
straight up you can do this online
consultation with them and then they
ship it directly to your door and
discreet packaging I've said it a
million times put blue two on it I think
it's something to show off and be proud
about but here's a great deal I'm still
waiting for mine to come and I'll let
you know what what happens when it gets
here but if you want one you go to blue
to calm you get your first order free
just they give it to you for you just
got to pay five bucks for the shipping
you just got to use our code which is
new rock and ewr Ock five bucks for the
shipping again is blue to calm so BL you
e CH e W calm and promo code new rock
I'll wait while our guests here go ahead
and fill out their orders straight women
of America a big favor
so marina you yeah I mean you just to
the blue for fun right it's not your
tobacco is that I have the biggest stick
of them all that's true my belly buttons
been erect for longer than 24 hours what
should I call your priest you're in
charge now all right guys also every
week we we we've been playing a game of
rogue theory with our patrons in the
discord and this week we selected there
were two great pitches
what the plot of Mandalorians season 2
is so we had a great submission from
Kyle offend 2187 that we really liked
but actually our winner when you combine
audience and judge votes is composer 95
who composed a really cool plot around
and I want you guys to respond to this
theory it's gonna be mando having to
unite the tribes of the recovering
Mandalore to defeat Moff Gideon who we
met earlier and honestly who's gonna
have to help them in order to do that
because he can't do it alone the tribes
are all in factions of course ahsoka
tano yeah so what do you guys think of
that idea for a Mandalorian season - I
like that idea I feel like that's if you
imagine what's the the broad arc of the
series it begins with the Mandalorian
people scattered even the name
Mandalorian is kind of disambiguates you
don't know his name everyone's kind of
anonymous so going from that to the
finale being everyone reunited and
having a name and that name meaning
something yeah that makes sense on a
kinetic level for sure also like it
makes sense for a character arc because
the whole first season is him basically
not wanting to be a dad and only wanting
to take care of himself and him learning
like okay I have to be responsible for
like another another living thing and
the whole Mandalorian culture is like no
I'm I'm out for myself like I'm a bounty
hunter I'm only taking care myself and
visit this that season would be another
arc of like going from an
individualistic mindset to like no let's
essentially unionize and get everybody
to work together or or even beyond
unionize like family eyes right that's
something that happens a lot with new
parents especially new single parents is
they have to now make some some
decisions how much do I want to do this
on my own versus go back to get help
from my parents reconnect to my family
and then beyond that if you're from the
smaller culture you're from the more you
have to decide actually do I need to
teach this culture and bring this
culture into this life so that was like
sending it back up the family tree in a
way is very much what new parents have
to deal with speaking as a parent of
many children
daddy exactly my grandson dad sunscreens
are all right guys so you can play along
too and you can join now the likes of
these great champions composer 95 it's
the most recent you get a special little
designation in the discord when you've
won discord rogue theory am I gonna do
is become a patron and hop over there
and we play every single week guys the
new theory I want to talk about they're
moving all of the movies that we need to
see to far away and I'm very nervous
about it and it it means so many bad
things but it also means an amazing
20:21
potentially it but one of the biggest
implications could be the timing of the
Black Widow release they have not
announced it they delay Black Widow on
us which okay they're delaying
everything but we all know the MCU is
just so carefully woven together from
the web of Feige and now suddenly they
might have to push this movie late what
if they don't want to push it what if
they don't also want to push the Disney
Plus shows like Falcon and Winter
Soldier stuff now suddenly their design
of their timeline is gonna get knocked
out of whack we have previously talked
about what's gonna happen in the Black
Widow post-credits scene we have
previously said oh it leads perfectly
into Falcon in the Winter Soldier so I
want you to scrap all that forget it
it's not gonna happen marina instead I
want to know if they push Black Widow
out past Falcon the Winter Soldier
then what post credit scene are they
gonna have to suddenly shoot last minute
throw in there and make it a perfect
setup for Black Widow to connect to
something else that's coming in the MCU
not related Falcon on Winter Soldier
let's hear your theories oh you yelled
at me so I'm gonna start about yelled I
mean just said my name at all so we're
watching Black Widow from our Disney
Plus accounts at home in 2021 everything
is back to normal
but Disney Plus is just and releasing
movies directly onto that platform now
which will never happen but in our
dreams it can and we watch the whole
movie we're staying in our seats and at
our home at our home we don't get up and
dump popcorn on the ground nope
and we watch full 30 minutes of credits
and then we see back to the end of
endgame Natasha Romanov wakes up on warm
air soulstone in hand right
and she goes what the hell I'm supposed
to be dead and then that perfect
impression just go with me that wasn't
too bad actually
it does kind of have a little bit below
it it needs a little rasp
yeah rasp yeah and she sits up she's in
the water and she hears a voice from
behind her and it and it goes Natasha
Romanoff Romanoff and she turns around
and it's Doctor Strange okay in an Iron
Man suit woo yeah and he goes we have
work to do so basically in a cut Saban
so this is basically a tie-in from the
Black Widow movie to Doctor Strange
multiverse of madness and that movie is
basically gonna be pooping around say no
more we know the exact but it is Doctor
Strange going through different
universes and different realities to
realities where the characters that have
died in a different version he can save
them or bring them back and and bring
them and reassemble them to fight a new
villain who could be Doctor Doom is my
pick that's my preference and so it's a
total it's not a radio because I think
that would be like cheap like oh wait
they're just undoing everything they're
not
doing anything these are totally
separate realities and the entire movie
is getting to see these different
realities and different characters that
we lost in a totally new adventure say
Quicksilver Quicksilver yeah boo oh yes
yes that's awesome collecting all our
dead characters and just bringing them
back very cool why is he in the Iron Man
suit because he can do it all cuz cuz
Tony's not using it anymore well I mean
it's such a great imagine if you already
have the powers that Doctor Strange has
but his weakness is his body so he might
who's a lot like me he was just like
they buried him and he was like excuse
me can I just borrow oh I'm just gonna
scoot squeak this off you and he just
like takes it away and everyone no one's
mad at him yeah I like his trading card
of the kicker's like strengths magic all
this of brilliant or a weakness body
general by the way in a dick to things
that would be huge here though well now
did Black Widow need to be added to
multiverse of madness if she wasn't
already but I guess there's time to
reshoot that but also I'm gonna throw
and this is this is where you get a
inadvertent Rogge yeah yeah marina there
you go and this is because you made it
so Natasha post-death can wield an
infinity stone in her hand which means
she came back different yeah that's the
whole thing we don't know what that
would mean how she came back but so
Black Widow plus powers I mean look what
you could do without powers maybe she
maybe her power now is like she can
bring people back from the dead who
knows also the Robie turned into a piggy
bank oh sweet he's our stuff inside of
it it's really heavy again you'd like
your camera now yeah so much so much
careful we're gonna Rob you yeah all
right I love it it was next okay I've
got one here so Black Widow ends we're
assuming maybe red Guardian dies right
it seems like because David Harbor has
to die right that's that's in his
contract and it says rose characters
have to die but we boom movie and sad
like windows triumphant but read
Guardian is is dead maybe some other
characters died as well we go back to
the prison where red garden red Guardian
was broken out of and in Russia Siberia
wherever and it's also the prison that
stranger things
David Harbor will be as well there's
only one Russian prison and the gulag
yeah yeah everybody knows the gulag and
and maybe there's like a warden we saw
from earlier maybe some prisoners we
recognize they're milling about and we
see like some Case Files you know in the
top one is red Guardian and then the one
right underneath it it just says Peter
Rasputin open it up boom its Colossus
okay and then maybe the file underneath
that Weapon X but it's written in like
the Cyrillic alphabet or whatever so it
just looks like googly because that
that's a but we can tell the X so we can
tell the X part and then open that up
boom this is our entre the Weapon X
program mutant kind right maybe there's
some hints of Wolverine Sabretooth
Deadpool what somehow this connects and
I like this because like it makes sense
Costas is Russian so like we're spending
a lot of time in Russia and in Black
Widow but also this is totally
unexpected this is not something that's
on the phase four line up anything to do
with with mutants or classes or even
Deadpool so it would be like a fun
unexpected post-credits thing for Black
Widow yeah and and sticking one and it
doesn't require many reshoots or
anything right because it's just it's
not about Black Widow in that and I
think you could get away with
introducing Colossus that way in the way
that they did Scarlet Witch and
Quicksilver where they're not mutants in
the MCU they're like experiments and so
we know that Russia done its own
experiment if they try to create their
own
Iron Man or Steel Man or something you
know but literally he can turn to that
with the skin there's actually there's a
character on agents of shield that that
was pretty similar to that so maybe
that's yeah that's a good way to bring
it in I like it cuz you brought in a
mutant just really same one how can I
tell the difference yeah they're they're
all the student I actually only have one
roll of toilet paper this rogue s still
has the hard time Phillip somewhere your
fiance's exact are you done yet alright
Eric what do you got okay
so throughout the trailer footage for
Black Widow one thing I pointed out and
what keeps calling me crazy is Natasha
is holding these glowing red vials and
it's they seem completely like literal
red herrings and people are like oh it
could be anything and I keep saying they
look a lot like Pym particles that we
see the pictures in game that are
basically the method the the flux
capacitors of time travel in the MCU
right and they especially look like Pym
particles in the Funko pop toy figurine
and the toys never what they don't look
if they aren't Pym particles what are
they then cuz they don't look like
anything else so I think we're gonna see
this movie and you're not gonna see them
show up at all we're gonna be like aha
it's gonna be like that extra hole
footage that they shot for an infinity
war it wasn't in the movie at all it was
just something they threw in there just
to distract us and send us down these
Theory rabbit holes until the
post-credits scene so we're gonna find
out what exactly happened at the end of
Civil War so Steve Rogers broke a lot of
these people out of the raft prison
right well in tow Steve Rogers is Falcon
and Natasha Romanov also people who got
out of that prison where Scott Lang and
Clint Barton but for whatever reason
they ended up in like government
lockdown after after these events so
you're gonna see how Natasha was
intentionally trying to get a Scott Lang
out of there but Scott Lang had these
extra Pym particles that he gave to her
and says I don't want the government to
get their hands on these you hold on to
him and the post-credits scene
throughout all the events of Black Widow
Natasha has to leave them behind but
they're left behind wherever she was
staying
wormhole opens it is Loki and
time-variant Authority agent chrono
monitor played by Owen Wilson they pick
up these Pym particles and look he's
like it's good thing we got these before
anyone else did and Owen Wilson goes
yeah cuz Kang was gonna get here real
quick let's go take these back to HQ Wow
and Kang's on his way and Loki coming
out on Disney Plus very soon hopefully
no no Kang compression yeah who's gonna
play Kang Oh Richard grant right Richard
grants gonna be it Loki and he's gonna
play Kang the Conqueror and he shows up
afterwards and he kind of also has a
British accent right he was in Houston
Logan and he was in the rise of
Skywalker
this was my big bad records Wow Erik you
get a self pimping Rogi oh I do yourself
out can you drop it drop it it's a
Valentine relay for February guys never
happened all right
let's hear him back in a tweet it's a
ghost emoji and a lemon and then a girl
going like this okay and then a robot
plus a doctor emoji and then a unicorn
because that's the magic of those two
universes coming together and then the
entire representation of the multiverse
of Madison is a unicorn because there's
it's just magic
man help in isolation so uh so we gotta
conserve your words you just gotta
speaking of boat keys now yeah that the
tweet is entirely in emoji code and
anybody who correctly interprets it gets
all these mini rooms one Rogge those
confess those more than one okay okay
Black Widow who's gonna defeat her I
don't know but here's this guy Peter she
done beat all her bosses to make way for
Colossus cuz here comes a Russian man
made a metal hash tag Tommy Becht oh wow
so bad not bad yeah bad yeah I'm fine
either way I'm with a Russian man is
gonna beat her great Eric okay so my
tweet is a parody of that gal gadot
imagine video I know it was like two
weeks ago whatever so it starts with the
Paul redis Scott Lang saying imagine
there's no future and then hands over
Pym particles to Scarlett Johansson she
says you try and then hands it off to
Tom Hiddleston's low key and he says no
future or past and then hands it off to
Owen Wilson who says Wow some Pym
particles in my ass and then Richard
grandes kang pasta there's like imagine
any gets cut arm with past yeah I can't
argue it that that's it that's all right
Eric I appreciate all the effort but the
Rogi of this round is gonna go to Jack
for the tweets there you go I I
appreciate it all the rhymes this time a
lot of those emojis Ryan people pick up
on that but they did all right all right
guys it's not done yet it's time for
real question
30th anniversary of the original Teenage
Mutant Ninja Turtles movie who has the
best pitch for which turtle they are and
why Donatello
because I'm a scientist but instead of
using science it's just me rearranging
all of the ingredients in my kitchen and
trying to make it into a real classic
Donatella with the bo staff I'd like to
think of myself as Michelangelo because
I am a party dude
but I think probably more accurately I'm
Raphael and I'm just an introvert you
know you take know - yeah I'm shredder
because they keep having to shred the
final square of toilet paper I have my
bathroom was the largest room in our
apartment set this up it already had all
the camera equipment so we talk about
all things that are relevant pop culture
on this show and on this channel and we
can't go forward without acknowledging
our tiger king Lord and Savior all right
so I the biggest issue a lot of people
are having with the show Tiger King is
that you find that none of the
characters are redeemable at all or even
very likeable so give me in your best
impression of a tiger king a character a
defense of why that characters actually
your hero that you're rooting for oh
I'll go first
only I'm not a smoker otherwise just
picture me with with like 10,000
cigarettes in my finger and I'm strict
deco the like reality TV producer in the
cowboy hat say my life was forever
changed my G exotic I was never the same
after that fire I also I connected with
him as an off-screen producer I connect
with my fellow off-screen producer Rick
Danko
the his defense is that it's it's Joe's
out exposure it's all your fault okay
I'm I'm I'm John Finlay who's his
husband but or his ex husband but not
Travis pretend that I'm Bob and that
I've done a shitload of Medicine okay I
[Laughter]
don't even know
that's legitimately one of his last
moments which it to be fair as a decent
argument of why we should support him is
that he had no idea he didn't even know
he was gay I know he wasn't I think this
show is redeemable if you just choose
that that one former GW Zoo employee was
redeemable like oh you can you could
save it with just like two months of
therapy not cut it off wait there's a
new prosthetic that allows you to work
with it for two weeks late nah I'm good
what yeah you don't even have to cut it
off it was just a dream yeah and also
it's the most Star Wars yeah actually
I'm okay with it not a great defense for
most of those people so marina at least
yours is the most accurate I didn't
blame it on the math it turned into a
chapstick yeah that's chap sticks all
right guys I didn't keep count so who
won what are you cooking what are your
totals I think I believe I have four I
have three I'll scream producers are
is our winner of this episode and I
don't know what your wishes of wanting
to tell us well I really loved in a
recent video Eric made Eric an editor
John did a very quick fun thing where
they turn to Eric and do exotic Joe for
just like a single frame and I would
love it if if sorry editor John if you
could make all of us like give us the
dumb mustache and the weird mullet gonna
go on marry each other now and just like
the end of every episode of rogue theory
that's it thank you so much to our
guests
Zach Huddleston our winner this week
Thank You marina master so you missed
you it's nice to see that you're getting
on and no one thought it would happen
what do we got going on well what we got
going on is the fact I'm governor of
Oklahoma I'll make polyamory mandatory
[Laughter]
under septic tanks the only way you can
be in a marriage and what's our next two
MCU rewatch
comes the closest to a doing all right
y'all don't forget to subscribe to rogue
theory as a podcast feed and go ahead
and say do news YouTube channel and also
hard footage of just us saying terrible
things about people we hate that we want
murdered and then they'll use it against
us in court
hello Twitter new rock stars and me at
Bill Bolling on Instagram and Twitter
[Music]